the European Union has agreed on a new
massive Aid package for Ukraine despite
threats from Hungary to veto the move
for weeks the European Council president
says in the end all 27 leaders have
agreed to the support package totaling
more than 70 billion Canadian dollars
the announcement follows previous
objections by Hungary to veto the deal
it's not clear at the stage if any
concessions were made to hungary's
leader Victor Orban to secure his
approval I think we should focus on the
fact that today is a good day for Europe
we have to do that we have been for many
weeks uh keeping our Ukrainian friends
on tenter hooks as to whether we would
reach an agreement uh and the fact that
it was reached so early on is also uh
thanks to the work hard work done by a
lot of our leaders um in order to bring
um it to a resolution which includes all
27 we will always protect the rule of
law uh the case has been brought
questions will be asked have been asked
uh is it an ideal scenario no but have
we found unity and unanimity today yes
so I think we should welcome that and we
should really send the strongest of
message which is the opposite of what uh
Putin would have wanted I'm grateful for
your decision on the financial
instrument for for us uh for our people
for Ukraine Ukraine uh facilit with 50
billion EOS uh for a 4E period This is a
clear signal that you Ukraine will
withstand and that Europe will withstand
it is also really important that this
decision was taken unanimously by all
all of you all 27 member states and it
is yet uh another clear sign of your
strong unity and support of Ukraine the
last time a European council meeting was
held credibility of Europe was at stake
and we all together strengthened that
credibility the EU has proven that its
word matters and its promises work for
the interests of entire
Europe